[MUSIC PLAYING]
SETH VARGO: Hi there,
and welcome back
to our eighth episode
on SRE and DevOps.
My name is Seth, and
I'm a developer advocate
at Google focused on
infrastructure and operations.
LIZ FONG-JONES: And I'm Liz
Fong-Jones, a site reliability
engineer at Google, where
I teach Google Cloud
customers how to build and
operate reliable services.
So last time, we were talking
about [INAUDIBLE] alerts.
And Seth, you were
really, really skeptical
about letting go of your alerts
about every single potential
root cause in the system.
SETH VARGO: Yeah, honestly,
it's terrifying to let
go of all of these alerts
that we painstakingly built
in the past that have happened
as a result of an outage
or would have prevented
an outage from happening.
LIZ FONG-JONES: I
totally hear that.
But what we need are better
ways of finding problems
in our systems that
don't necessarily
rely on making assumptions
about what's broken before,
rather than layering
on technical debt
after technical debt
after every outage.
SETH VARGO: So I've heard
there was a word for that--
observability?
LIZ FONG-JONES: Yeah, that's it.
SETH VARGO: We need to make
our systems observable,
rather than only
being able to debug
what we've thought to log
or monitor or alert on
in the past.
LIZ FONG-JONES: Exactly.
So observability breaks
down into three key areas--
structured logs,
metrics, and traces.
Structured logs are
emitted by each process
and may contain a
mixture of information,
ranging from records of
individual user queries
to debugging information
generically associated
with our service.
Metrics reflect
aggregate-type data
about the performance
of services,
such as the number
of queries, which
is a counter, their latencies,
which is a distribution,
and the CPU load,
which might be a gauge.
And traces allow for
individual execution flows
to be traced through
the system, including
timing and dependency details.
SETH VARGO: So I see, and
all of this makes sense.
I still don't understand.
How does this help me better
understand and diagnose
my problems?
LIZ FONG-JONES: Let's
take an example.
So we use metrics as part of
our service level indicators,
right, in order
to monitor outages
that are spending our
error budget faster
than we can tolerate.
So once we have an indication
that something's wrong,
we need to figure out where
in the system it's broken.
And can we mitigate it by
draining a zone or specific set
of replicas?
And we might need to drill
down into the metrics
in order to find out what
are the commonalities
between the slow and
erroring queries?
For instance, do they have a
shared zone, or a shared set
of dependencies, or
maybe a different version
of the code that is new
that we just rolled out?
So we might use
traces after that
to find the interaction between
the components that's causing
the slower failing queries.
And we might need
to use the logs
to understand each
failure in detail.
SETH VARGO: So if I'm
understanding correctly,
once I get paged, I might look
at these kind of dashboards
of all these different metrics
with common starting points
for queries, such as break
down by region, et cetera.
And even though I'm only getting
paged on these kind of higher
level issues, I'll still
collect information
about these lower level
issues, which could
help me debug the root cause.
LIZ FONG-JONES: Exactly.
And then you'd need to edit
your queries to further drill
down or get
breakdowns intersected
with other properties,
for instance,
the build version or the
set of feature flags.
You don't necessarily need
to alert on every metric
you collect, just
on the error budget.
But having that
information available
really, really helps when you
do need to diagnose problems.
SETH VARGO: OK.
So I'm with you so far, but
then where does tracing come in?
LIZ FONG-JONES: If you
see that queries are still
at the top level, it's
often helpful to be
able to skip down
directly to where
you think the problem
might be happening,
layers deep in the system.
So the best and easiest
way of doing that
is having a visual
representation
of where is the time
spent in your queries?
Where is the new bottleneck
that's increasing your latency?
SETH VARGO: OK.
So I've pulled up on
the traces dashboard,
and I can see that
most of my queries
are completing in
about 50 milliseconds
in Cloud Big Table.
But there are a few queries that
are orders of magnitude larger
taking longer to complete.
I also notice that many
of the slow queries
happen to be on the same
row in Cloud Big Table.
LIZ FONG-JONES: That
sounds an awful lot
like a hot spot, Seth.
SETH VARGO: Definitely.
It smells that way, too.
I see now, and I can
look at the relevant logs
on individual replicas that
the tracing is suggesting
to help understand why that same
row is being queried repeatedly
and why that query is so slow.
So I can see how this
architecture helps me identify
and solve problems faster.
But what if I'm not
already using these types
of observability tools?
What if I'm coming from
a traditional monitoring
solution, or kind of
embarrassing to admit,
but I still [INAUDIBLE]
through log files manually.
How do I get started
with something like this?
LIZ FONG-JONES: Don't
be so scared, Seth.
That's a great question.
I'm glad that you asked.
Google Cloud offers a suite
of tools called Stackdriver,
including Stackdriver
Monitoring, Stackdriver APM
Trace, and Stackdriver
Logs that let
you adopt all these techniques.
And there are really
cool integrations
between all of these various
observability methodologies.
But you should start by
measuring your SLOs first
in Stackdriver Monitoring
and Stackdriver SLO.
SETH VARGO: Great.
I'm glad to have learned so
much today and hope all of you
did as well.
Thank you for
watching, and we hope
to catch you next
time, where we'll
discuss how to resolve incidents
with as little chaos as
possible.
To find out when we post
our upcoming episodes,
please like and subscribe below.
[MUSIC PLAYING]